لقد نشأت وكان صيادًا في
الوقت الذي كنا فيه أطفالًا ، فهذه هي الطريقة التي نعيش
بها ، إنه مجرد احترام كبير للبحر
والجبال الجليدية والطبيعة
[موسيقى]
ترى بلدة الصيد هذه ، فهم
يخططون لإنشاء مطار جديد
والبناء والإنشاءات والفندق
الليلة سيكون كبيرًا جدًا في غضون بضع
سنوات ، ونحن عادة نصطاد سمك السلور ، والبعض
يسميها سمكة الحائط ، إنها أقل من الآن
الآن بارتيمان انتهى به الأمر في مارس من
الوحدة النمطية ، إنها حالة شاذة في AMIA West
Arkansas ليس  حتى أتمكن من المرور بعدي ،
أتخيل الآن أنه عندما نذهب بعيدًا ،
نذهب للصيد الشراعي ،
يكون ذلك نوعًا من الاسترخاء في طقس لطيف
عندما يمكنك رؤية الطبيعة والجبال الجليدية
ويكون لديك الشمس في غضون 24 ساعة عندما يكون
شخص ما تبحر  تشعر
بالحرية ، يمكنك أن تقول إن
[الموسيقى
] صعب في بعض الأحيان ، لكن من السهل أيضًا أن
يعتمد داتشيون آخرون على
اليوم بالنسبة للصياد
الذي لدينا مصدر للعيش من
البحر بطريقة الصيد والصيد الجزئي
[الموسيقى
] للصيد الذي لديك  هذا جيد  من أجلك ولكن
عندما تشعر أيضًا أن السكان المحليين
بحاجة إلى الصيد - ومن الجيد
أن البحر يوفر العيد
[الموسيقى]